The dagger represents
the conjugate transpose, which we already saw for vectors when we talked about the Dirac
notation a few moments ago.
Here we're performing the
conjugate transpose on a matrix rather than a vector, but it's essentially the same thing.
We transpose the matrix, which just means that we
swap rows and columns, so the JK entry becomes the KJ entry,
and also we take the complex
conjugate of each entry.
Also, this notation right here
means the identity matrix.
These two equalities right
here are actually equivalent. If you have one, then you
automatically have the other.
They're both equivalent to
saying that you is invertible, and the inverse is equal
to the conjugate transpose.
That's only true for square
matrices, by the way. If you have a matrix that isn't square, then one of those two
equalities might be true,
but then the other one won't be true.
But here, we're talking
about square matrices.
So this is the standard
definition for unitary matrices, and it's nice because it's easy to check
if a matrix is unitary.
You just multiply the matrix to its conjugate transpose on either side, and you see if you get
the identity matrix.
There's an equivalent way to characterize unitarian matrices, and that is that a
square matrix is unitary if and only if it never
changes the Euclidean norm
of any vector when you multiply. An N by N matrix U is unitary if and only if the
Euclidean norm of U times v
is equal to the Euclidean norm v for every n-dimensional column vector v with complex number entries.
And therefore, if v is
a quantum state vector, then U times v is also
a quantum state vector because quantum state vectors
are simply the vectors having
Euclidean norm equal to one.
In fact, we can say a little bit more, which is that the unitary matrices are precisely the matrices that always transform
quantum state vectors
into quantum state vectors. That's a similar situation to what we have for stochastic matrices
and probability vectors.
The stochastic matrices
are precisely the matrices that always transform probability vectors into probability vectors.
So once we've decided that operations should be represented by matrices, which is the same as saying that transformations act linearly
on vectors representing states, these choices for the sets
of allowable operations follow naturally, at least,
in a mathematical sense.
Now let's take a look at some examples of qubit unitary operations.
We'll see many more examples
of unitary operations in subsequent lessons, including unitary operations and systems
having more than two classical states. But for now, we'll focus just
on qubit unitary operations.
We're going to be seeing these
particular examples arising again and again, so it's definitely worth getting
to know these operations.
The first collection of examples are the so-called Pauli operations.
These are the operations that correspond to the Pauli matrices, which are shown here.
They're all unitary, and you can check that for each one according to the definition from before.
These particular matrices
happen to be equal to their own conjugate transposes, which is to say that they're
all Hermitian matrices.
So checking that they're
all unitary, in this case, is a matter of squaring each one and seeing that the result
is the identity matrix.
The names you see for these
matrices are pretty standard, and you'll also see sigma
x, sigma y, and sigma z called simply X, Y, and Z.
Do be aware, though, that the
capital letters X, Y, and Z are also commonly used for other purposes, even in the context of
quantum information,
but they are very common
names for these matrices.
The sigma x or X operation
is also called a bit flip or a not operation, which we've already seen
in the classical context.
And the sigma z or Z operation
is also called a phase flip.
And here, you can see the
action of these operations on the standard basis factors, which kind of explains
where these names come from.
Certainly, it makes sense to
refer to sigma x as a bit flip based on this action right here.
It simply flips the bit from
zero to one or one to zero.
It also makes sense to
call sigma z a phase flip based on this action right here.
But if that's not crystal clear
at the moment, that's okay.
We'll encounter this
operation over and over and the significance
of putting a minus sign in front of the ket one
basis vector and not ket zero
and why that's called a phase flip will be more clear later on.
The next example is
the Hadamard operation, which is represented by
this matrix right here, which is pretty much always named H.
Checking that H is unitary is once again a
straightforward calculation, which if I step out of the way, you can see right here.
Similar to the Pauli matrices, H is its own conjugate transpose.
So we have this equality right here, and when we perform the multiplication, we get the identity matrix as is required.